oh you're gonna [ __ ] up your yeah yeah I
better reverse it yeah just um my hair I
miss that one oh there we go lissandra
swere call for now and for naught
robert handlery how are you doing sir
hello Danny oh you caught me just uh got
a little snip snip here yeah well we're
off duty so sure I nosh I cielo Thundra
is that doing your oh I like it she cuts
the best hair in the city it's a good
cut em I'd get my haircut except my hair
is perfect thank you how are you today
sir I'm doing very well Danny how are
you great we're off duty today and there
are apparently rockstar verified a bunch
of new death maps and races death maps
sure perhaps now that sounds good that
from the community so how about we go
check though that that would be a
fantastic idea i hear their community
made community made yeah i'm just gonna
I'm gonna try and shoot I wish I she'll
come back to shoot in the face mom
alright we are here so Barney this was
full some base this pooch oh it's what
it's hard work guys oh hey what's up
guys now it's cool we're just gonna go
to do super Monaco Grand Prix yeah
audition yeah and tell tell bill to have
those papers on my desk tomorrow morning
it's me I got a haircut here we go yeah
monaco grand prix GT a edition look out
no formula 1 cars but we got this I got
this sweet purple infernus you and your
hot ass j GT race is turned on so uh
yeah oh [ __ ] you bro look out grenades
oh you people Ward's to oxygen grenades
oh yeah you were the word Oh sucks
alright Rockets headies the Rockets
again looking at all yours that get you
troll me yet hell yeah car flipped over
twice this has grenades and up and used
on a racetrack since niki lauda crashed
in spa Frank and chomp back in the 70s
all right race rules like break you shot
him a tire tire fader does happen in
Monaco quite a lot Sox team orders team
orders I have to shoot you rockets oh I
don't remember it was talking to
construction they said that there's a
road closed and they do not recommend
going down it all right such a jerk
which I do it a go oh I'm gonna say I
gonna say that it was wisely did I oh
wait wait have to go back around this
way I just got a call from them they
said it was the other side of the road
oh really I gotta take this video I
don't remember the part in Monaco where
you drive through the ghetto I'll be
honest pretty sure Monaco doesn't have a
get over yeah all right well they should
have won it should work that that's all
right dude hey what's up Oh where's oh
shoot Danny I got some rockets like I
get rid o enough going ok I enjoy your
car [ __ ] oh you're gonna [ __ ] up your
yeah yeah I better reverse it yeah I
just um my hair I miss that one oh there
we go let's undress work all for now for
North Georgian have got popular formula
one would be if this is what you doing
it and this next one is called Terry's
hangout which which is a team that much
event which is the only one attempt Lane
County it's the only one of these and
creator weekend things that actually is
set outside of the city of Los Santos
hmm did you steal Terry's plane I may
have stolen his plane that might be why
Terry's gang was after me okay I have a
friend who whenever he's a he's caught
by the police he comes into the middle
of this wind farm a man just stands
there and all of the police choppers
just get eat [ __ ] off the Indians yeah
loses his stars should I all right great
Steve going yeah we lost another water
oh my god you gotta stop doing that Mike
going call your next sounds good dead oh
did you [ __ ] do cuz you I was trying
to look for you I just beefed it Oh
tricky oh man out of this job before
this explodes Terry's hang ash they came
to the wrong hangout sure did work hops
were professionals let's get him let's
murder these fools um oh he's easy I got
I got a nice one nice thanks for
flushing him out you got it the scum he
is just like our training Danny just
remember your training oh there is I see
him okay you go out so I'm gonna go
around the other side oh here he's come
today here in the roof oh he's on the
roof on the room thoughts yeah yeah what
can eat it [ __ ] Florida let's just
keep murdering them until we hope he's
on the roof are there is hahaha nice oh
yeah we broke out a bit of skin in that
game oh hey what's up
you too huh I'm gonna rob is I'm gonna
take his money drug money all get it
evidence whereas we are bashing them
they're milking these guys 2516 guess
you could say I'm bash and Brandon
that's alliteration little arias
everyone watching at home if you're
gonna make up your own GTA mapserver
thing don't make the game half an hour
long is that a [ __ ] we could just we
could just camp we could just disappear
we could just get on a plane right now
and just leave see it see you Brandon
see you bright let's just run away
that's not this connecting to server
let's just run away see if he follows us
yes we've got a 10 kill spread so we
just run away then in vain we win maybe
this convict a just run away for 64 16
minutes and let people in big jacket
this is the best tactic ever all right
there sells a race yeah well you're out
here we go oh [ __ ] whoa this is pretty
good a pretty good race I'll be honest
yeah well oh he just [ __ ] nailed me
from behind stop nailing me you your
pink [ __ ] oh look who's right behind it
sir that's for her hey I can see your
booty back home I could love it Oh to
see the last one of us [ __ ] oh how is so
clutch oh yeah that was great that would
easily do it I'll watch your face bro
what's your face yeah oh so Danny that
was some good stuff yeah rocks that's
the latest additions to I guess the
Rockstar verify to keep adding in all
these user-created a Maps a bit of a bit
of a mixed bunch I come how do you feel
about the ongoing future of Grand Theft
Auto goes up to be honest personally I
think some of this stuff is getting just
a little bit dry or not as interesting
as auto yeah I think I think they're
taking their time with it they're
milking it if there's anything that I
know it's like the metaphor way madness
like let's get real like that was pretty
interesting that was great that's what I
was hoping more stuff like that more
kind of bright dumbness um but yeah that
was that that's it shortly love that I
guess on what's what's going on here the
only fitting way to to finish this is to
have a fistfight ok so look I'm doing
right now so when we look away ok ok on
the count
swaggin just fight off of this because
[ __ ] thing because if GTA diaries has
taught us anything it is this the most
fun you can have in Grand Theft Auto
online is the stuff the fun you make
yourself that is so true damn and with
that three two one go oh [ __ ] i ate it
too I in a tube oh no tell my wife I
said hello oh god that's good I love me
the cops were called because you're a
fighting on top of them hey you can't
fire fair thanks Rob all right x value
next time